it was truly a
unique memorial and they didn't
want these to be lost stored safely
inside a library at unlv so each t-shirt
was is individually identified i believe
it's about 400 boxes
5 000 t-shirts peter michelle is the
keeper of a collection of cotton
memories of one of america's darkest
days cataloged and saved we document
history in whatever way we possibly can
it's what las vegas and visitors left
behind
a memorial at our version of new york
our lady liberty and the city she calls
home if you were a fireman visiting las
vegas you would have had this t-shirt
these are individual hats from fire
companies t-shirts hats
patches and poems all too soon the
coward strike firefighters police and
tourists alike
leaving a piece of them for all to see
to see
and to share to share their own grief as
a fireman in thinking about firemen in
new york city when you actually hold up
a t-shirt and hold a t-shirt you
understand somebody was wearing that
t-shirt that belonged to an individual
fireman somewhere who also puts his life
in danger every day the question for the
hotel is what do we do with these 20
years later they remain unwashed and
untouched just like they were that day
and in the months and now years after
with hand written
not forgotten a glimpse of how we
grieved
in order to learn in the years to come
this is a physical artifact of a moment
in history that i think has to be
preserved
the plaque there now outside new york
new york now part of the preservation
includes educating younger generations
about what happened that day by seeing
how our community paid their respects
can't believe it's been 20 years david
charns 8 news now christian